down
what's with the jeans you know it's so
weird I mean it's not weirds an ongoing
theme is that I can't hold my farts at
all lately you've been mentioning this
no I know but it's constant like I for
it everywhere now it's a pretty
liberating it's like your year of free
farting was it 2014 I think was 2012 the
year of Justice yeah because at 2011 it
was 2011 going into 2012 yeah those of
us where I don't that we were checking
in for the flight and you ripped one guy
at the other side of the yeah it was one
of those self check-in terminals or the
monitor front he went 2012 bro
for when I want a why I want what I want
far whatever I would thank you you
farted yeah no shit
mr. white folks far as well he lost the
fuck he farts whatever he wants to fart
okay but it's a problem when I get
massages now cuz I really have to clench
extra heart and I ever have to take into
consideration what I'm gonna eat before
I know ruins a montage well I just have
to think now like oh I can't have
certain food items before I've spent
entire massages holding my bunny tail
and aren't you terrified of falling
asleep of course and you know it's gonna
eat well then you're like oh maybe I'll
be more than a fart that won't be so
good you can't shirt under stomach when
you're laying on your stomach you sharp
well if you had a real loose loosey
goosy in there though you didn't know it
yeah you very excuse yourself to go the
bathroom no never
during a massage enough u4p for yellow
yeah I've done that like once or twice
yeah I try not to I'd rather just hold
it through the whole thing that's the
worst but if you relax enough you don't
feel it sure but you got to be that
relaxed yeah you just go use your mind
you know yeah relax
yeah this parts not gonna make any noise
Shh you let one of those out of course
of course and then what is she saying
she's like I'm gonna go get some
aromatherapy stuff I left in the other
room she goes no more pleasure boy too
much